[Music]
today we're going to do our lecture on
world under ten girls champion Rochelle
Wu from the state with the hotbed of
chess activity Alabama and her dad as a
professor in in Birmingham I think well
my friends to rachels was in Tuscaloosa
it's unfortunate somebody has to live
there and Rochelle plays chess almost
every weekend her USCF rating has been
over 2000 for a while she's 10 years old
um current world champion from Soviet
Georgia and she plays a lot in Atlanta
area in the Charlotte area but not so
often in Atlanta for obvious reasons
okay and if they ever get to learn how
to read Alabama they might get a chest
book and get some chess go in there I
said if okay
and I'm not telling they have to do that
so the way who did they vote for Alabama
all right so this coincidentally these
games were all from the world
cadet which finished last month which
Rochelle won and didn't lose any games I
believe she had eight wins and three
draws but if I'm wrong she had seven
wins and four draws it's one of them you
guys can look it up and complain the
internet later the only thing you're
good at
you're not even good at that okay
terrible all right so this was a game
she plays she has the black pieces
Rochelle likes to play wild and crazy
Rock'em Sock'em chess checkmate her
opponent tactics tricks etc etc mainly
etc etc the other stuff I was just
kidding okay so she plays the Kings
Indian she has the black pieces and she
plays a very aggressive way a lot of
people who were lower rated always put
their night on d7 but nights a little
more active on c6 and then she plays the
move g5 and Knight f d7 this is very
interesting I think maybe once or twice
in my career
when I'm white in the Kings Indian I've
had somebody played 9fg seven and then
try to just crush me I think once I won
and once I got crushed
so 9fg seven normally in the Kings
Indian when you want to move your age
pawn I'm sorry you're F pawn the plan on
f7 and your knight is obviously in the
way you play Knight h5 sometimes you
take the bishop and you play you know
all your pawns forward I think this idea
is interesting because black decides I
don't want to take this bishop and trade
my knight I want to trap the bishop okay
it's more aggressive idea and the knight
on g7 protects a five so it's sort of
hard for white to stop f5 and e5 and
white doesn't really have great counter
plan the Queen side so it's not so easy
to play here for black for white I
should say I think this idea of 9ft
seven was one of the ideas by the coach
that we had in Georgia for Rochelle John
Fedora whites and many of you remember
John Fedora wits when I say many of you
at least one of you and uh he's a New
York grand master lives recently married
actually to the woman that he's been
married to anyway for 25 years they
decided to get married for real fact I'm
getting married soon possibly before
this video is shown based on what I'm
hearing from Ben Simon remember sin hate
mail to Ben Simon
he won't delete that out either because
he likes that on so I might be a married
man when you see this so very suspicious
then I'll have many more jokes to make
that's good for you at home okay so 9fg
seven and blacks just going to push all
over pawns forward and crush white let's
see what white does about that see three
solid f5 the at the points h3 ah you
know I don't really know what to suggest
for white White's playing really solid
but this idea of black play e5 and f4
that's annoying okay and I know annoying
because I'm getting married for the
third time so so I'm not really annoyed
right now but when you watch this video
then there's going to be some good stuff
so if I was white here I would be very
upset because when I play lines with
white that involved Bishop g5 or Bishop
f4 and they're playing g5 and they're
doing stuff usually my opponents play
Knight h5 and take my bishop so I don't
lose my bishop we're going to trapped
here I'd be very upset because if my
opponent plays a 5f4 that's not good and
even if I save my bishop by playing h3
Bishop h2 what kind of Bishop is that on
h2 terrible so these are the kind of
games I lost a long time ago and then by
not playing very often I lose less I did
pretty good
okay so h3 e 5 again Rochelle likes to
mix it up not only am I trying to win
and trap this Bishop I'm currently
threatening a fork of these two pieces
although that might not work as a Bishop
c4 jack but it might work
d5 attacking the knight Knight to e7 and
I don't really see the counter play for
white I just see that black has a big
attack now after the movie 4 I remember
looking at this game I was like looking
over Fedor what's his shoulder weight
he's pretty big I was looking over
rachelle shoulder and we were in the
analysis room and I remember we were
pretty upset here and then about 5
minutes after we were upset
Rochelle checkmate and took all our
opponent's pieces so we were like all
right she made up for it by playing
better than we would have if I was black
I would play f4 and I would win because
I would have an attack on the Kings side
and my opponent's dish upon Age 2 would
be trapped
but Rochelle wanted to open it up and
that's that doesn't make a lot of sense
because then white's pieces aren't all
trapped
so definitely f4 and then h5 and g4 and
Knight g6 and move your arms like this
the thing is we're shells arms are
pretty small 10 year old girl so this is
not too impressive yeah so that's why if
I did it then you know rawr so I don't
like this move taking on e4 although I
will admit I still prefer black because
black has the open F file Black has the
open
agonal for a bishop Black has f4 and f5
for her Knights so I still prefer black
pieces here but I don't like this this
trade and neither did John okay
so blacks better not but maybe less
better than she was and this is one of
the issues that we usually have with the
children is they like when it's open
they like to do stuff and we're all we
don't like to do nothing like even go
into the analysis room was a chore it
was like on the top floor don't me push
the elevator button and wait for like a
minute so you know doing nothing that's
my specialty you could ask any of my
wives okay even the ones I didn't marry
okay and you can ask these people here
but they're too lazy to answer they're
like I don't know alright what okay so
Queen f6 our attack and again
irrespective of whether blacks attack
will work
there's something else in chess that's
what is your opponent doing and if
somebody can tell me what White's doing
I'll listen
White's Bishop on h2 is terrible the
knight on f3 doesn't have a good square
white doesn't have any Queen side attack
and a lot of King's Indians when black
is doing this White's playing b4c 594
and breaking through on the Queen side I
don't I don't see that here so blacks
having all the fun okay the night went
to e7 opening up for the black pieces
and black and play g4 and stopping white
from trading more pieces later Bishop g3
now that the ninth on f5 I think I would
have done that and she plays c6 again
not a move I probably would have even
thought of I'd be thinking how do I make
my opponent and I'd be having my head
tilted over to the Kings side but
Rochelle is a very aggressive active
player she wants to win on all the sides
of the board and put a lot of pressure
on her opponent and this reminds me of a
funny story
hopefully it's 20 minutes long and then
you can edit it out it's about two
minutes long I played somebody rated
about 1600
when I was about 2,200 and the game was
a really long boring draw and I was
talking to a friend of mine it was
high-rated than me and I said why did I
not beat this 1600 like what what I
didn't blunder so like they should
blunder that's their job and he said you
didn't do anything you didn't give them
any decisions to make or put any
pressure on them so they just made
random moves you made random moves it
was a draw and he was right sometimes
I'll make bad moves like I did yesterday
against Danny Machuca or as you guys at
home would say two weeks ago if I'm
Waukee three weeks ago maybe and I mean
I could be divorced by the time this
video shows that's like 50/50 okay so
was I saying
let's see marry divorce third time lucky
McKenney Machuca coffee Starbucks let's
see where was I oh yeah
so sometimes when you put pressure on
your opponent and your moves are wrong
you win pretty quickly as we saw top
love in the first round of the showdown
against Cara Juana one person nodded but
they're just not in pretending
pretending like they know what I'm
talking about they don't talk about okay
and I remember the common stairs were
like what stop we love doing and then
top-level easily that's what he was
doing and so even though I don't like
taking on e4 c6 by putting pressure on
white white has to make some decisions
and when your opponent has to make
decisions they're going to be the wrong
decision for example you at home you had
to make a decision on the day that we
voted and you made the wrong decision if
you just stayed home then everything
would have been fine but instead you're
like oh I have an idea I'll vote for
Donald Wow really showing your
intelligence good job okay
so now look what you got the CEO of
Hardee's is going to run our country
soon okay so if you can win a wrestling
match with Linda McMahon all right so
what was I saying to an idiot you're an
idiot at home okay
so see six maybe not the right move of
putting pressure on your opponent now as
I was saying earlier my game with Danny
Machuca I made four or five blunders but
those blond
years made it difficult for him to find
the right moves he was a computer he
would be salivating it would go into his
circuitry I would have won but since he
was a human he was like he that moves
hard to meet I think all hey mate in one
and then I won okay so I actually won in
nineteen moves I made four really bad
moves if I made no bad moves I would
have won like 30 moves so it's good
thing i blundered
okay so c6 I don't like it but I like it
later well then then I changed my mind
okay h4 now this follows my rule put it
in H but you know okay don't move funds
in front of your king and white plate h3
and then h4 this must be why white plate
h3 a Bishop g3 last move now black
should be checkmating light and white
should be breaking through on the Queen
side instead that players are confusing
me because they're ten years old they're
lower rated they're very active players
and I like to do nothing
c6 @ h4 I've never played such moves
well when I was 10 I did Nana lost a lot
when I was 10
okay so Knight f5 or as I like to say
knife f5 there's a there's a good player
you must have beat Nick Carlo in a blitz
game a few weeks ago yeah cuz knife f5
now here's one you don't know you at
home can try to answer who's the first
person who said knife f5 and I stole it
from them it was a 1984 in Moscow
anybody a Greek Grandmaster no nothing
exactly Vasily Escoto Gnaeus he said
then it's not Knight f5 it's knife f5
now he meant with white because when
white gets the knight on f5 then that
not an f5 is pretty good too I must
admit but that's not what he meant
but I'm going to steal it anyway so I
don't like h4 because Knight f5 attacks
all that stuff ok and obviously the
bikes got a lot of stuff over here we
got a lot of pieces and white doesn't in
whites rooks no good Queens hiding
ok knight on f3 can't move anywhere boo
okay so hg hg opening up the h file just
what white wants pause not so h4 and
trading on the h file who did that help
the h file opening I'll tell you in five
moves when white gets checkmate on the H
file is white rook and queen coming to
the H file as we say in German is shown
think so okay blacks Queen in red going
to the H file opening the H file in the
King's Indian when White's doing
intentionally what is this the world
rolls under ten oh wait a minute mine
okay so Rochelle is pretty happy because
she is getting help with her attack
Bishop back to H to g4 yeah if I was
white I would resign even if I apologize
just to show the proper etiquette I'm
just kidding okay my vote was 1200 they
would resign here with black right here
okay Knight d2 the Knights attacked
Knight d4 23 Bishop h6 night b3 King g7
now I already told you the answer but it
was like one minute ago so I have no
faith in you why did black play King g7
get the rook over to the H file and then
put it in H white put it in H now black
is going to put in an H but blacks not
kidding I was just kidding
and then black plays rook h8 and either
Queen h4 Queen h6 that's not good
remember there's good and there's not
good that's not good
Knight a5 because that's very important
see that's where all the play of the
game is no yeah all right talk about
misunderstanding the situation Rick H a
and Knight takes b7 and black resigned
because she's down upon okay so remember
when you're playing me if you can play
Knight d2 to be 3 to 5 b7 make sure you
do that when I'm aiding you okay good
job okay Bishop f4 even the class can
see the threat there's too many threats
were cage to Bishop h2 computer probably
wouldn't do either one of those Queen h4
might be even better
yeah yeah Bishop eight choose the best
one which may excuse maiden four or five
okay so Bishop g3 stopping Bishop h2 and
obviously you're telling Claudia what
yeah the octane six and as I like to say
the truth hurts yeah so white played
Bishop g3 Bishop h2 Bishop g3 Bishop age
to Bishop g3 and opened the H file on
purpose and somehow guy made it so as
we're looking at the game we were like
Rochelle why did you do this and why did
you do that and then we were like good
job yeah so Rochelle try to open the
game gave white a lot of complicated
decisions White's decisions weren't very
good
h4 was a terrible decision Knight b3 to
a5 to b7 was crazy and black just
checkmated white easily that's one of
the reasons she won the World
Championship now before I show you one
of her better games in the tournament I
want to show you the game well I mean I
want to leave forever okay I want to
show you the game where she actually won
the tournament this was the last game
and this is a very nice tactic so as you
can see black is winning okay you don't
need an advanced degree in hyperbolic
topology to realize blacks winning hello
would help okay and white is basically
instill me you can solve this with some
kind of King's Indian to in fact she
also played Knight FG 7 this game and
then pushed all her puns
okay here white defends it a little
better but black spawn on e 2 is pretty
good and also blacks rooks are good and
Queen is good and up a pawn and there's
more advantages but it's only in our
class
okay now white wanted to trade
everything off and get her King to the
center when the e pawn so she played the
obvious Queen g1 and her idea was if
black trades Queens the King goes to g1
the King goes to f2 and if you win the
e2 pawn there should be a draw very
reasonable
and if you don't win the e to pawn
you're just going to lose so Queen G
one's a reasonable move it's the only
way I could ever win the e pawn this
position I don't even see legal moose
for white horrible okay so I like Queens
you want now Rochelle calculated all the
way to the end winning all of White's
pieces if you can do that you should do
that okay that's one of the advantages
of being a very strong junior player
that's what they're good at they're good
at calculating forcing variations where
you resign at the end and usually not so
good at other parts of the game although
if you're world champion usually you're
good at everything so who in the
audience could tell me the absolute
force to win for black and actually one
of the reasons I like this since I'm so
old it reminds me of a game that I
played I've played a lot of games and it
always reminds me of something several
years ago in the spice Cup and I've
lectured about this game I was playing
gene ippolito the Dean of American chess
and I was a rook down playing my usual
you know solid game and I had several
passed pawns he was winning that he was
drawing and when he was drawing he
decided he didn't want to draw and he
played a forced win unfortunately it was
a forced win for me and I won the game
and the way that I won was the same way
Rochelle won this game so I I like that
although Rochelle unlike me isn't down a
rook but she doesn't have a passport on
e to which I did have so so how does
black win you've all I've been talking a
long time to give you guys a chance to
solve it anyone John no nobody Claudio
okay trade Queens and rip to d1 and now
if it was blacks turn to move which it's
not what would black do take on c1 take
on c1 Rik d1 check so white play King f2
it's the same right and take on c1 and
root D 1 yeah in fact when I played Dean
he had his rooks on the back rank and I
took on b1 I think and then I played d2
and I had passed pawns on e 2 and D 2
and neither one was attacked so that
wasn't good
if I taken his other rook I would have
lost because his King would have come
forward so I like taking the rook over
there and then winning and after rook G
1 obviously the game's over white
resigned and black was the world
champion this is how she finished the
tournament but I like the way she's
strategically winning and I here just
finds a forced win because another move
that look as good as Queen g3 check and
then after king h1 white isn't stalemate
why can't move anything and that's what
probably a lot of grandmasters would do
is keep you know squeezing the Vice at
making sure you couldn't move but
younger players and computers just
calculate the forced win okay and I'm
old so I can do that I miscalculated
lose my e pawn and I lose so I like I
like this really nice calculation rook
takes c1 if you don't see rook c1 rug d1
you can't play Queens e1 our queen g1
just like in the Carlson game you can't
play rook c8 check unless you see Queen
h6
it wasn't like king h7 didn't see that
oh I'm lucky I have Queen h6 okay he
played rook c8 check in the final game
he saw Queen h6 before he played it and
again that's what a computer does it
plays the quickest way to win not the
easiest most humans play the easiest way
to win but I guess if it makes you the
world champion you might as well meet
your opponent yeah okay and last but not
least at least was this engine that she
won and I really like this game because
unlike most ten-year-old girls she
played a very sharp Grunfeld and this is
just her style some people some would
call them sexist say that you know girls
are afraid when they play like Emily
Trask don't want you know like no that's
attacking I don't want to calculate but
in fact at the World Championship and
the higher rated players
the young players are super aggressive
super like Emily Trask that's right now
been in chess not in real life okay
and I stereotyping young and old players
now that I don't work you take somebody
like Viktor Korchnoi I mean he died
several months ago but he's still a
favor against most of you okay and when
he played chess even it is in his 80s in
late 70s he was tough and he would beat
you all kinds of ways and Krissi yep is
a good example of a young girl who likes
to play very sharp I'll calculate you
trick you run you over basically and
well that's what we have here with
Rochelle whoo she's younger than Chris
yep and slightly lower rated but very
very similar style like run over your
opponent give them decisions to make and
they make the wrong decision and that's
the way we're shell plays and she plays
the Grunfeld my transposition and here
we got why could play e4 which would be
a more normal Greenfeld okay and here we
have like a symmetrical pawn structure
which I mean four players under 2200
it's very hard to play white it's not
clear what to do white was given the
center but black is going to keep
attacking it bishop a3 Queen a5 very
aggressive already dish up a six and you
can see whites retreating and black has
all of our pieces developed and is
castled
White has all of our pieces about but
hasn't castled yet and you can see when
there's a bishop that's fianchettoed on
the same diagonal as a queen and rook
advantage bishop okay and also c3 is
weak black's pieces are all great so big
advantage to black already castles b5
again b5 not the kind of movie I would
expect from a young player who's afraid
of their opponent I would expect it from
a wild and crazy' player like Steve
Martin okay so obviously if Queen takes
b5 the bishop on a3 is hanging and
official takes b5 we're
be eight either one pins the Bishop of
the Queen but b5 is a very aggressive
move is Blackett I leave the pawn on b5
forever black gonna play c4 is black
going to play b4 and black has the
initiative White's Bishop on e3 is
trapped so very bad position for white
already h3 is this the previous game
where the night went to a5
what does age-3 have to do with anything
Rick a be a queen c1 getting off of the
bishop on g7 and the rook on b8 a very
passive move and sometimes when I'm
playing badly or have a bad result and I
look at my game I can actually look at
my own moves and not look at my
opponents and I'm like oh yeah I play
Queen b3 Queen B - Queen c1 that's what
I wanted to do okay you look at blacks
moves all very natural going forward
gaining space and when white played
Bishop a3 her intention was to put
pressure here but that didn't happen
like why didn't do anything
rook c8 great position for black Bishop
retreats again and takes on d4 it's hard
for that white Queen to escape the black
rooks Knight b6 all kinds of good
squares for black just a great game if
you play the grünfeld
or grin felt like systems this is what
you dream of is black it's a nightmare
we have a very famous chess coach avi
Friedman walking in yeah what do you
think white or black you know are you
surprised that White's Queens made a lot
of moves you're like wait a minute did
white just fly queen c1 now Queen b3
Queen B - Queen c1
- ship a3 Bishop b2 yeah okay now the
game is over soon as far as if Eve and I
are concerned but it's a junior
tournament so we play on and so we can't
play anymore which I also do ok Queen d2
because you move the Queen enough
Knights e4 black has the two bishops and
the better position and
everything the rooks attacked on b8
something I would miss Queen c7 and very
good end game for black because the two
bishops the weak bonds the bad bishop on
b2 this bishops gray this bishops gray
and no active plan for for Wyatt but
it's a kids tournament so attack a
Bishop Bishop to d5 rook e1 and after 94
she played b4 and now white blundered
although this is no fun when I say
blundered I think the computer said like
blacks up 1.6 and after the next move
it's up like 3 because it's a blunder
it's a tactical mistake that she made
and this is the kind of move White's
been dreaming about for the last few
moves and finally she gets to do it when
it's not possible but did it anyway ok
just play Knight c5 the knight is great
on c5 and threaten Knight a 6 and it
blocks the rook on c7 wow what a move so
when your opponent lets you play a move
like that you might want to be
suspicious
we have grumblings from the highest
rated player in the room
what are you grumbling about what's
going to happen yeah the truth hurts
yeah yeah when your opponent can make
captures and you're like oh yeah
then you yeah and I was saying the whole
lecture wow what a great Bishop on g7
and you were thinking what are you
talking about
that this was not doing anything ok but
now as Claudio mentioned now that Bishop
is pretty good
yeah so as soon as white got one active
piece then white had to resign
immediately
now of course Aviva and I would resign
and then we would go to the good
Georgian place maybe Paulie would take a
cab about two dollars yeah then we'd
order everything and get somebody else
to pay yeah that sounds like what we
would do yeah okay
instead juniors so you got to play on
forever okay for our now it looks like
you're going to lose the rook but
juniors are tricky see saving everything
okay although too
Bishop's is better than a ruck if you
weren't sure you're going to find out
I remember one this gives me good
memories many years ago in the
Netherlands I had two bishops against a
ruck Wow was that fun
not for my opponent man my dish observe
great okay so two Bish's versus a rook
and again resigning is always the
correct move but it's more fun when they
don't resign then you get to get lots of
queens and win the rook and all kinds of
good stuff and basically why can't do
anything and the truth hurts and then
kept playing very suspicious yeah so a
very brutal win thinking and played so
mate if there's no well probably white
saw the game Kasparov vs. Kia your yev
was that the game while making FLETC
when I make fun of the right person
that's right yeah
yeah so it was a blitz tournament
because tomorrow I've had a queen and a
bishop against a king and he still made
it him
so if Kasparov came here with the Queen
and Bishop he felt I shouldn't resign
also there's the famous game are you
levy been Feingold Targa levies about 20
180 Michigan expert sometimes he's a
master usually an expert and he had
Queen and Bishop against my king and he
also still be enemy in a slow game and
then he was not happy afterwards I can't
tell you at home what he did because
it's g-rated I'm always g-rated all
right and then King F for double x clam
I would have played King aged six
unprofessional King safe run h6 it feels
like and the point of King aged six is
you're in Wing Chun or King F for White
has one legal move yeah anybody see it
really nope where yeah King a two and
then mate yeah I want to play King aged
six because safer although the clock
side you're right usually so King f4
does make more sense now because you get
one motion
all right so that was a brilliant game I
think that was her best game of the
tournament black in a grünfeld type game
and just rolled over her opponent the
other game was more fun because she was
black in a King's Indian checkmated her
opponent but this seemed more like out
playing your pawn strategically and then
tactically finishing the game off and of
course the position that I showed from
the tournament I only show cuz she won
the tournament that mean or the world
champion so very impressive and as you
noticed because I told you every game
wins with black almost all of her
drawers are with white because she's
always playing fighting chess that's how
you win these Swiss tournaments and I
think the Americans have a small
advantage over the Europeans in the
world youth because in a lot of
tournaments in Europe like the London
chess classic starting tomorrow or for
you at home ended last month you know if
you get like one win and a draws you're
clear first by a wide margin okay now
that wasn't funny to anybody okay but in
the world's use if you have one win in
eight draws then you know you came in
27th so in Swiss tournaments with lots
of players you got a win win win win
okay you can't be like all draw five
games and win two then I come in first
okay which in some super GM tournaments
is the truth so in a lot of European
tournaments where the players are all
good at it's one round today you want to
have like two wins and seven drawers or
three wins and six draws maka via style
but if you're playing in tournaments
like this where you have to get nine and
a half out of Loven to win you have to
win with black and white and you have a
very active style Kings Indian Grenfell
type openings not Queens gambit declined
at the Berlin okay no draws and so in
the world youth we see a lot of decisive
games and people are playing actively
and that's what the spectators want to
see we don't want to in London chess
classic I want to see that maybe you
guys on all the results at home I don't
know nothing they're so smart all right
so hopefully it's a not December 19th
yet so know who the president is but you
know we'll find out all right and now as
with any good lecture ending it ends
with the important sentence time to get
Thai food
[Music]